THIS FIGHT.
>> AND I KNOW YOU WILL BE
COVERING THIS FIGHT FOR SURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME IS FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF MICK MULVANEY.
YOU'RE A FORMER LAWYER, YOU ALSO
WORKED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU CAN PROVIDE UNIQUE INSIGHT
HERE.
DO YOU HAVE THINK TRUMP'S
ATTORNEYS HAVE A CASE HERE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
PROBABLY.
IT'S VERY UNCLEAR.
THERE'S A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
PRIVILEGES HERE.
THE ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS
DIFFERENT FROM EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS HARDER TO
OVERCOME.
THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS VERY
MURKY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR AS TO WHOSE
PRIVILEGE IT IS TO INVOKE.
FOLKS, WHEN I WENT TO GO TESTIFY
BEFORE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, THE COMMITTEE GOT A
LETTER FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAIVING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE FOR ME.
I THINK YOUR PREVIOUS INTERVIEW
JUST DID A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
EXPLAINING A LOT OF THE
VARIABLES.
PAT CIPOLLONE AND PAT PHILBIN.
IT'S A VERY, VERY CONFUSING SORT
OF MORASS OF PRIVILEGES.
THEY'RE ALL VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE SERIOUSNESS
OF GETTING INTO WHAT A CLIENT
SAYS TO AN ATTORNEY, INTO ADVICE
PEOPLE GAVE THE PRESIDENT INSIDE
THE OVAL OFFICE.
DOESN'T SURPRISED ME TO SEE THEM
LITIGATED TO THE Nth DEGREE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE YOU KNOW HOW
CLOSE THEY WERE TO THE
PRESIDENT, DAY IN, DAY OUT.
IF D.O.J. PREVAILS HERE, WHAT DO
YOU THINK THE IMPORTANCE OF
THEIR TESTIMONY WOULD BE?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY BECAUSE I
WASN'T THERE BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THIS IS THAT BOTH MR. CIPOLLONE
AND MR. PHILBIN, DESPITE WE MAY
HAVE DIFFERENCES ON POLICY, I
WOULD DEFEND THEIR INTEGRITY
20%.
THESE ARE VERY, VERY HELPFUL
GENTLEMEN.
IF THEY PROVIDE TESTIMONY THAT
WOULD HELP THE PRESIDENT, THAT
WOULD CARRY WEIGHT AND IF IT
HURT THE PRESIDENT IT WOULD
CARRY WEIGHT AS WELL.
THE LAWYERS HE HAD, EMMITT
FLOOD, TY COBB, REALLY, REALLY
CREDIBLE.
>> THERE WERE DISAGREEMENTS
BETWEEN YOU AND PAT CIPOLLONE.
YOU MADE CLEAR THERE WERE POLICY
DIFFERENCES BUT YOU COULD ATTEST
TO HIS CRED IBT AND INTEGRITY.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT ANOTHER ONE
OF THE MAJOR TRUMP
INVESTIGATIONS.
A SPECIAL MASTER REVIEWING
DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO
ORDERED TRUMP'S LAWYERS TO BACK
UP HIS CLAIMS THAT THE FBI
PLANTED EVIDENCE AT HIS FLORIDA
RESORT.
SO THIS SEEMS TO PUT THEM IN A
TOUGH SPOT, EITHER SIGN A SWORN
DECLARATION THAT EVIDENCE WAS
PLANTED OR NOT, BASICALLY
ADMITTING TRUMP LIED.
>> IT'S VERY INTERESTING TO ME
AS A FORM ARE LAWYER AND TRUMP
INSIDER AND SOMEONE WHO WORKED
IN THE WEST WING, THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THE BRIGHT
LINES DRAWN BETWEEN POLITICS AND
PUBLIC RELATIONS AND THE STUFF
THAT REALLY, REALLY MATTERS AND
THAT'S THE LAW AND CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
SO WHAT YOU'VE SEEN A SPECIAL
MASTER IT DO THIS WEEK IS A
COUPLE DIFFERENT THINGS, WHICH
IS I'VE HEARD YOU FOLKS IN THE
TRUMP TEAM SAY YOU HAVE
DECLASSIFIED THESE DOCUMENTS.
IT'S TIME TO PUT UP OR SHUT UP.
HAVE YOU ACTUALLY DONE THAT?
AND IF SO, I WANT COURT FILINGS
BACKING THAT.
SIMILARLY HE'S GONE TO THEM AND
SAID IT'S TIME TO PUT UP OR SHUT
UP.
GOING ON TV OR A NETWORK
INTERVIEW ISN'T THE SAME THING
AS SAYING IT TO A COURT.
A SPECIAL MASTER GETTING
INVOLVED IN THIS CASE, AGREED TO
BY TRUMP AND THE D.O.J. IS
SEPARATING NOISE AND P.R. AND
BRIGHT SHINY OBJECTS FROM THE
STUFF THAT REALLY MATTERS.
YOU CAN LIE ON TV BUT YOU CAN'T
LIE ON COURT.
>> BOTH SIDES AGREED BUT IT WAS
TRUMP'S TEAM THAT ACTUALLY
SUGGESTED HIM IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
SO IT IS NOTABLE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU BEFORE WE
LET YOU GO ABOUT THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
IT IS RETURNING FOR A HEARING
NEXT WEEK AND AHEAD OF THAT YOU
TWEETED, QUOTE, NOTHING SCREAMS
GREATEST THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY
IN 150 YEARS LIKE TAKING SIX
WEEKS OFF FOR VACATION.
NOW, THE COMMITTEE SAYS THEY'VE
BEEN INTERVIEWING MORE WITNESSES
DURING THIS TIME, THEY'VE BEEN
GIVING INFORMATION TURNED OVER
FROM THE SECRET SERVICE.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT'S NOT A
LEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION?
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION IS REAL.
DO THIS VERY CREDIBILITY
CHALLENGES, YES.
BUT THEY'RE STILL THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND FBI.
JANUARY 6th IS A BUNCH OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS, THEY'RE
LEGISLATING AND GETTING
REELECTED.
THERE AS NO WAY YOU COULD MAKE A
CASE THEY'RE UNBIASED PEOPLE.
HAVE THEY BROUGHT FORTH
INTERESTING EVIDENCE?
YES, THEY HAVE.
IT CERTAINLY HAD VALUE BUT THEY
ALWAYS STRUGGLED FROM A
CREDIBILITY STANDPOINT BECAUSE
THEY HATE DONALD TRUMP AND THE
HEARING IS DESIGNED TO MAKE HIM
LOOK BAD.
I THINK IT'S COMMON SENSE TO SAY
THIS HAS BEEN THE GREATEST
THREAT EVER TO THE HISTORY OF
OUR NATION AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
AWAY FOR SIX WEEKS.
IF I SAID YOU CAN SEND ME A
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT TO
ASK WHERE I'VE BEEN FOR SIX
WEEKS, YOU CAN'T DO THAT WITH
CONGRESS BECAUSE THEY'RE OUTSIDE
OF FOIA.
I THINK IT INCUMBENT ON THEM TO
TELL US WHY THEY HAVEN'T HAD A
HEARING IN EIGHT WEEKS NOW.
>> WE WILL BE ASKING THEM.
WE NOTED EARLIER THEY HAD BEEN
PUTTING TO THE INFORMATION,
TALK